welcome to the midterm review of 1413
so now as i mentioned before there will
be three time types of questions in the
exam
uh there will be true policy certain
questions these are questions when
you've given
a statement and you're gonna ascertain
whether the statement is true
false or answer truman's essentially
strictly true and it's always true or
false it's strictly false and
uh there's a counter example of division
it's false
and on certain means like um without
having further information
uh you cannot actually answer the
question necessarily you cannot really
make a statement whether that say is
true or thoughts
um in any of you what you do please
always
um explain your answers carefully so
just
writing true false uncertainty will
almost truly or will surely
not give you full credit you have to
explain your answers
it doesn't actually matter that much
whether you get it right
the statement is true or false uncertain
as long as your
answer is actually reasonable and sort
of show some understanding of the
material
and you know so so and the quality of
the answer is quite important
we also wanted to write intuition so we
do not want to just write some math um
and nothing else you can use some math
to
clarify your answer or the like but you
always need to provide a verbal uh
explanation and some intuition and some
explanation of
why you think um uh the answer might be
or that statement might be true or
false or answer
from all the choice questions
essentially you're giving uh different
choices and you just pick one answer and
no further explanation
very simple and then there will be sort
of piece outside questions that sort of
you're familiar with either from like
the psets or like
previous um exams uh these will be quite
similar
in the presets question they will be
generally um not on the hardest side
just
we have so much time to do this there
will be some algebra involved
again please always explain your answers
um
careful
now what materials are you responsible
for
uh you're responsible for the lectures
talk to you and including lecture 12
which is election on march 11
uh up to uh slide 67 of lectures a lot
more lecture the notes for a lecture the
handout of the notes for
um lectures 11 to 13. we're also
responsible for recitations on p5
recitations 6 which is the reservation
that will give
which is quite similar to this one and
uh seven this recitation various reviews
that might be helpful um for some of you
but there's no
new material psets one to three
um part of the deal
and uh readings um start and non-start
readings
citing in class are um only relevant to
the extent that they appear in lectures
and or recitation but to say like if i
discuss a certain paper
and the content of the paper content of
the people that's discussed in the class
it is relevant to you however on uh
anything that's in the paper that
doesn't appear
in the lecture it's not relevant doesn't
like you're not going to ask me
questions that sort of ask you about
some of the
details of the papers that you've never
heard about in class
uh how do you get ready for the exam
well um and you
study study the lecture and presentation
slides carefully
um you should um uh make sure you're
familiar and comfortable with the
presets
and the solutions make you understand
and are able to solve the pizzas
on your own great resource practices
google's presets and exams
um again uh readings uh starred and
non-start are not required but they may
sort of help you deepen your
understanding of the material maybe
sometimes collection works a little bit
um dense and don't have that much detail
so you sort of like try to consult them
and try to understand materials
are better but we won't ask you about
the details of those readings um
uh uh beyond what was um
beyond those details that were always
covered in class
so let me now sort of review the
material overall and sort of give you a
sense of what are the kinds of things
that we want you to know
to be clear this is not exhaustive in
the sense of life
there are some other materials in the
lecture slides that i'm not mentioning
here what i'm trying to do is just give
you a sense for a lot of
the most important key things that you
should know
those will cover perhaps like 89 of the
material that's actually potentially in
the exam
having said that you should uh uh uh
surely go through the entire lecture
slides and make sure
to gather
okay so the first um i think we
discussed um these time preferences in
particular the
exponential discounting model here you
should know what is the exponential
discounting model
what is delta the time performance
parameter in that model
but does it measure how can we estimate
it assuming that an exponential
discovery model
is correct further one of the main
assumptions
of the exponential discount model
and what evidence do we have against
those assumptions so in lectures three
and four and discuss those
assumptions and the evidence against
those assumptions in detail
after that we discussed the
quasi-hyperbolic discounting model which
is a relatively
small modification of the exponential
responding model
again you should know what is this model
how it's different from the
exponential desktop model and of course
the difference is that there's a present
bias parameter
beta that is added
to um to this model which measures
um short-run discounting as of like how
much weight you put on the present
versus everything else that's in the
future now what
empirical evidence um uh can we cause an
exponential
uh quasi-hyperbolic uh model explain
better than the exponential discount
model and why is that
you should be familiar with for example
things like preference reversal for the
magical commitment
why is that consistent with the
quasi-hyperbolic model and
and you know why is it not consistent
with the exponential model of course
that's what we discussed in the previous
slide
to some of the assumptions of the
exponential model
where for example uh one of the key
assumptions are that there are no
preference
reversals you just have that in detail
then um of course you need to know in
the quasi-hyperbolic
discounting model what is this
sophistication what is
so what is beta measure um whether it's
beta hat measure
what is full sophistication humanity and
partial magnitude
and uh and so questions such as like
that sophistication make people
always better off and why or why not
further you should understand what is
demand for equipment
uh who demands commitment when he
doesn't so like are fully sophisticated
or for united people or partial 95
what are the conditions under which
somebody
demands commitment and what kinds of
people
um uh do not
do demand commitment and what kinds of
people benefit from
doing so and in particular uh can people
be worse off from being offered
equipment device
and why is that or required
next we discuss in quite a bit of detail
on global applications from a range of
different settings
um this is a lectures five and six so we
want you to do
to be familiar with those empirical
applications
um you should understand where the
quasi-hyperbolic model can explain or
cannot explain
um some of the empirical evidence uh
better than the exponential discovery
model um
um you know kind of like why why do we
think that
why the hyperbolic model is is a good
fit for some of the empirical examples
that i have
shown um then you need to be able to
um solve problems uh similar followers
to the problems in the problem sets that
you've seen before
problem sets where people either like
exponential miscounters or like for beta
um delta equals theta equals
1 and delta b like either one or 0.95 or
close to one
because hyperbolic discounters um at
[ __ ] and like
for the sophisticated portion of that
agent how does one solve such
problems of course we have plenty of
practice already in the
midterm examples also in some finals
uh so you should um you should use um
backwards to forward some uh reduction
or
iteration uh uh depending on the keys
and sort of discuss this in slide 62
of lecture screen 4 and slide 37 of
lectures five and six
uh there's also a recitation that covers
that in detail
so you should have plenty of practice of
doing so
now um let me now give you sort of some
examples of like what are some examples
of true false on certain questions
and uh how should you answer them so let
me sort of just read the statements for
you and you can think about this for a
second
and then i'm going to give you um the
answer so i'm
considering individuals to create a
delta preferences
um who only differ by their present bias
have like beta equals
between zero and one and suppose there's
a commitment savings device available
the willingness to pay for this
commitment device
strictly decreases in beta
now is that um true or false statements
the answer is this statement is false
now why is that well there's um again
like if you just correct faults that's
not gonna give you
uh for credit even if the fact the
statement is false
what you need to do is you need to
provide some further explanation
um ideally we you know provide us like a
somewhat detailed explanation
but yeah um you think's false uh if you
provided several examples that should be
better
than just one uh in this case um why is
it false well a
individuals might be naive right so in
particular
people are fully naive they will not be
willing to pay for any
anything for equipment devices so um
regardless of the beta
um willingness to pay will always be
zero so usually not
decreasing beta second the commitment
device may just not be effective at all
the commitment device is useful useless
it doesn't matter what beta is nobody
will demand equipment um
anyway and finally even as individuals
this is a little bit more uh trickier
explanation and i wouldn't necessarily
expect you
to know that answer but even if
individuals are fully sophisticated and
device is effective the commitment
device is effective
willingness to pay and may not be
strictly decreasing
in data and here's sort of an example
well if beta equals zero or beta equals
one
then individuals would be willing to
create zero for the commitment bias
right because you know if they equal
zero they don't care about the future
beta equals one they just don't need any
commitment devices
um but in between the the willingness to
pay might be positive
for beta speed between zero and one that
essentially means that um
willingness debate would be sort of an
inverse u in beta
again that's a bit of a tricky answer
like with the bullet point you didn't
necessarily
expect you um to know that answer but
you should be able to
to say or to answer a reason one or
reason two
of a specific case
um second example uh statement fully
sophisticated individuals can experience
large welfare losses from their present
bias
the answer is this is true why is that
let me think about this for a second
well the answer is that awareness of
present bias that is like sophistication
does not remove press bias
even if people are sophisticated um uh
you know the present bias is still there
there might be some commitment devices
some ways in which people are able to
overcome
their uh the losses associated with
present bias
but in the absence of commitment devices
uh uh
people may still make suboptimal
decisions and some of these decisions
uh might in fact induce large welfare
use we discussed some examples in class
uh it's a numerical example you can see
that sophisticated people might actually
be worse off than many people that could
in fact
um suffer quite a bit from or similar to
large welfare losses the present bias
all of this is evaluated
by their long-running chill ideas and
like if somebody makes
uh choices for the future um uh
where the data is not relevant uh
compared to this with that kind of
wealth of criteria
uh people might be a lot worse up due to
their welfare uh due to their present
bias
okay here's example number three present
bias individuals always have
positive demand for commitment devices
again the statement is false
why is that and you kind of discussed
this already in the previous
questions and let me still be very
explicit there's sort of three
conditions that
must be met for positive demand for
equipment and discuss this in class
uh the person must be present biased or
have some
force or some self-control problems
individuals
that person might be aware of their
present bias so they can't be fully
naive
they could be partially naive but they
can't be fully naive
and the individual must perceive the
commitment devices effective in helping
uh overcome the self-control problem
that's to say if somebody is offered a
commitment device and that commitment
device is useless
well there's going to not be any uh
demand for equipment particularly if the
person
perceives that the commitment devices is
uh
useless notice that that person might
actually perceive the commitment device
to be effective when reality is not so
they might have some positive demand for
commitment even if the
commitment device is in reality useless
because their beliefs are wrong because
of essentially
um some form of partial retail um
but it cannot be that the person
perceives the commitment device as not
effective because then the person who
does not demand it in the first place
now that's my that makes now the
statement false when only the first
condition of the three is met as
like the person's only prison bias then
you cannot be sure
um that there will be positive demand
for um
commitment right and so the statement
um uh as it is said is false because
we said sort of like always have
positive demand for commitment
if it were without the always then you
know you could also answer like
uncertainty because then you would say
well it depends on
the an ibt or on the sophistication or
it depends on how effective the
commitment device is
but the way the statement is written it
says like always
and so now you can easily come up with
some common examples
that show that the statement in fact is
false
okay the second topic um that we
discussed after
time preferences was risk preferences in
particular expected
utility so here you know um you need to
have a
clear understanding of what is the
expected utility model
what is risk aversion why are people
risk averse
how is risk conversion specifically
modeled in the expected utility model
what is the expected monetary value
and also things like what is concavity
and
what does concavity have to do what is
the expected utility versus the expected
monetary value
and what does the concavity imply for
risk aversion
in the expected utility model
then next how can we measure the risk
conversion within the expected utility
model
in particular we discussed uh three
types of ways of measuring risk
conversion we discussed certainty
equivalence we discussed choices from
gambles
we also discussed um insurance choices
uh this is the sit in our paper
and then we discuss what is problematic
about the estimates of risk aversion in
the expected utility model
in particular we discussed evidence that
found that this
tends to be substantial small scale risk
conversions will give people
small gambles they tend to be quite
visceral so they tend to be
have a very quite high gamma but you
know we know also from large scale
choices that the risk erosion
uh intend cannot be actually that high
or when people make these choices
people leave their house every day and
engage in quite a few um
risks in the long run they hold stocks
and so on
that must mean that their long run when
using the longer choices that implies
essentially a relatively low
gamma now since the expected utility
model only has like one parameter
it cannot explain both of those features
and sort of
endure this um trouble so it sets you
when you if you try to
match a small scale risk aversion then
you need to have a very large camera
high gamma if you try to match large
scale risk vision you need to have a low
gamma
and that sort of brings uh trouble
because you can't just explain both of
those things
and sort of matthew rayburn and raymond
and thaler as well as recitation four
um discuss this phenomenon this issue
and in quite a bit of detail
next we discuss conneman and versky's uh
1979 prospect theory this is a seminal
paper
and uh if you should if you remember uh
just a few papers from this class this
is one of the papers that you should
really um
know about so what evidence is
inconsistent with respect to utility
well in particular so there's several
things in there but we discuss mostly
one feature which is risk aversion in
the game domain
and risk lovingness
in the last domain and so now what are
the most important points from conor
maynard percy's prospect theory this is
sort of the proposed alternative to
expected utility system
slide 3 of 51 of lecture nine
well there's three features discussed
there one is like changes
rather than levels or the arguments of
the utility function
then there's lots of version so there's
a kink
of the utility function around the
reference point
and there's the diminishing sensitivity
meaning there's um the utility function
is concave
in the game domain when it's above the
reference point
and is convex and velocity mainly below
the reference point
okay so now um what does this propose
uh alternative volatility or value
function look like how does it
incorporate the three features again we
sort of discussed this
um and that's the utility function in
lecture nine that
talks about this in detail or the
lecture talks about this utility
function in detail
one key question here then is like how
is the reference point determined what
are some candidate reference points
so one candidate would be the status quo
another reference point uh candidate
would be expectation
but there could be also other things
such as goal and aspirations
uh recitation five discusses this a
little bit um not in too much
detail now then um
we discussed empirical evidence in
particular what empirical evidence of
philosophers do we have
we talked about small-scale gambles we
talked about the endowment in fact in
particular
and then we discussed some applications
in lecture nine so what are these
applications we discuss
labor supply the housing market stocks
american running and golf
so you should be um familiar with these
empirical applications from lecture nine
you should in particular understand why
reference dependent preferences can
explain
some of the empirical evidence um uh the
issue
better than the expected utility models
you should understand you know
is some of the evidence that we see
consistent with the expected utility
model and why
if not why not and why is the reference
dependent model or would in particular
which feature of the reference dependent
model can explain false what are the
features again
uh changes rather than levels um sort of
some reference point reference
dependence
the loss aversion and diminishing with
sensitivity
and so which feature is actually
important in explaining things we focus
mostly on
loss aversion what is not relevant is
uh the deal or no deal evidence and the
paperback piercing
there's a couple of slides at the end of
lecture nine that i didn't really cover
or didn't cover at all
so you were not going to ask any
questions about that
um so now how do you solve problems from
reference dependent preferences you can
see problem set three uh question number
one had some questions about this
and again there's additional pieces and
exam questions uh that you can practice
with
quite a few of those kinds of questions
now um here's sort of some an example of
a multiple choice question
here's a so mattie wrote this question
so maddie in fact appears
uh the question is um maddie is writing
a problem set for 1413
she gets you to know the ufq from the
number of questions she writes she has
reference dependent preferences around
the goal of writing 10
questions tennis or often points
reference points
if you normalize the utility of 10
questions to zero
which of the following would be
consistent with
loss solution i'll let you have a look
at this so there's option a
u of a equals minus 2 u of 12 equals 1
u of 8 a number b option b and u of 8
equals minus 2
u of 12 equals 2 and then c is option c
is u of 8 equals minus 1
and u of 12 equals 2.
um so which of those answers is
consistent with loss division
the answer is option a now why is that
well lots of aversion sort of implies
that losses
hurt more than gains help so with
preferences as an a
maddie would have the utility of cost of
two from falling short of her
goal of two questions but only a gain of
one util um from exceeding our goal by
two questions right so the goal the the
gain of um
uh uh uh exceeding of being
a two question above um
uh so being two questions above gives
you some gain of one util
but the utility cost of falling
shortness two is twice as large which
just tends to be kind of like the
evidence that
we see in los aversion and the other two
examples don't have that so really only
um
answer number eight is is correct
um second question maddie is walking
home and passes a bakery
unexpectedly she decides to buy a pastry
for example she
sticks up the pastry and it looks really
nice prior to purchasing the pastry
her maximum willingness to pay for the
pastry was p zero
then she runs into allen's previous
excellent ta
who asks to buy the pastry for her she
offers in the lowest price she is
willing to accept
p1 which of the following comparisons
between p0 and p1 is consistent with an
adobe effect
p0 larger than p1 p0 equals p1
or p0 smaller than one
the answer is answer number c why is
that
well the endowment effect says that
people are
um when their willingness to to
pay this in this case p0 is smaller than
their willingness to accept
when they're selling something that is
to say being endowed with an item
in this case like a pastry increases
one's willingness to pay
that is to say um if somebody asks you
to sell something that you own
um you ask for more money than uh you're
willing to pay
in the first place when you don't own
the item and so
the endowment effect will then predict
that or the endowment effect
entails that now p1 equals is larger
than
p0 which is stands for number of scenes
so maddie values the pace two more after
she has spotted
um uh compared to like prior to buying
it
okay the third broad um set of
preferences that we discussed were
social preferences we didn't quite
finish with this so we're not going to
cover everything
in particular not lecture 13
and the estimation part of like social
preferences which will be in part from
or from
choices which will be at reset four you
should understand what social
preferences are
you should also understand how can we
measure um social preference
preferences in lab games we discuss the
length the dictator game the ultimatum
game and the trust game
um you should also be broadly familiar
not in detail but probably familiar what
evidence do we typically find in
dictator and ultimatum games
um for in for instance in dictator games
people tend to give something like 20 to
30 percent of their their share
um people tend to be quite nice in those
games
now then we discuss then like given that
evidence
given that people look quite nice in
these types of games
people also there's also some other
evidence people give and share to
charity or things like that
now do we think that is evidence of
people being generally nice to
others because of poor altruism uh
or um if not why not we discussed sort
of three sets of evidence in particular
we discussed uh the costly exit or exit
options in dictator games where people
essentially when they're able to leave
the dictator game the rather sort of
leave i'm not give
to keep the money or are they willing to
pay some small amount of money
to leave the dictator game of not having
to to face some other person
but they didn't feel compelled to give
to others there was the
option of hiding behind a computer so if
a computer
if you are a computer gives you the
option to hide behind the computer and
to be mean to others
you might um take advantage of that and
actually be meaner than you would be
otherwise so like altruism more people's
giving tends to go down
quite a bit when they're able to hide
behind the computer
and then there's uh so both of those
types of
pieces of evidence are evidence of
social image being important in giving
people care a lot about what others
think in particular what others think
about
them and they want don't want to upset
others and
so if they're able to avoid those kinds
of situation
um they might be able to they might want
to do that which would suggest that
it's not really that they want others to
do well in the sense that they really
want others to have money or have more
money
than before but rather it's because of
social pressure or social image concerns
people might um given dictator or
ultimatum games
moreover there's some evidence of like
self-image about people caring about
their uh what they think about
themselves they want to think of
themselves as being a good person
and so the evidence of the moral wiggle
room seems to
suggest that these concerns are quite
important
in particular people are engaging in
some behavior
um where they sort of delude themselves
that they are in fact
nice when in reality um they're not so
that's discussed in detail
in the lecture again we will not ask you
to be kind of familiar with this type of
evidence
um and you should be familiar why that
sort of tells us that people are perhaps
not as nice
as you might have thought they are just
coming from like dictator
ultimatum games or from like um
donations
we will not ask you about models that
estimate social preferences that will be
in
from support so don't worry about that
so the
stuff on like charnes and raven that's
there we will not ask you about that
okay so then um here's a another example
of the true false uncertain question
statement if a person gives a zero in a
dictator game this is evidence that this
person is
selfish um now uh the answer is false
i think if you answered uncertain that
would also be fine
uh why is that well the person might
give
zero uh to the other person in the
dictator game and then
uh donates the money to someone in
greater need right and then that
person's in fact really quite nice
um second the person might be very poor
relative to the other person in the game
so her marginal utility is just very
high
so now even if you have like you know
equal weights to like your own utility
and the other person's utility
um uh since the marginal utility of
giving ten dollars to yourself
compared to the other person is way
higher than uh the other person's
marginal utility
you might just give everybody everything
to yourself
um and that doesn't mean you don't care
about others it just means like
in fact even if you were um uh sort of
like a
social planner um you would give it to
that person because that person is like
a huge need or the rich person just
might not really need that money
i'm looking at this more closely
actually i think uncertain would be a
better answer here
not false i just wrote this question
fairly quickly
so if the question says um if the
question instead were to say
this is conclusive evidence that this
person is selfish
um then you know um it would be false or
this would be
this is clearly evidence or this person
must be selfish
um you know that would be false the way
it's written right now
it's rather sort of uncertain because we
just don't quite know it could be that
the person is really selfish
um uh uh or you know it could be that
the person
um it could be the this evidence of the
person is selfish
but it could be the other two reasons
that i just mentioned
uh okay so now um finally i'm going to
give you a long question or
example of a long question and this is
the question of
laptop policies we talked about this a
little bit earlier in in
in class in fact in the first lecture
and we had the first problem said about
this and this is sort of like an
algebraic version of
that kind of question so assume uh
the 1413 students are present biased
with
uh beta smaller than one and delta
equals zero
all students have the same beta smaller
than one and delta equals zeros but they
differ
in uh the value they derive using
laptops in class
yeah l is constant for each student from
class to class
but uniformly distribute across students
uh
on the interval between zero and one
okay
so there's you know uh some people have
a huge value of using the laptop in
class
and and others um uh do not
each lecture generates no immediate
utility so it's
neither fun nor like annoying with like
but it does give a benefit
a future benefit of v
okay so like you might learn something
or some some things that might be
valuable to you in the future using a
laptop reduces the longwood benefit by
deep this might be you know like
distractions in particular
so you might be distracted during class
when you use a laptop
so the the future benefits are
diminished by that maybe you
said something really insightful even
pay attention um and so now
um the benefits is b minus
d if you use a laptop both b and d
are the same for all students so there's
no variation variation
across students there the only
variations coming from like some
students who really really like using
laptops for various reasons perhaps
because you know they like to sort the
internet
perhaps they really need um uh
of using laptops because that allows
them to take proper
notes so in summary a student
uses a laptop in class uh sorry
a student that uses the laptop in class
gets immediate utility l
and future undiscounted utility of v
minus d
and a student who does not use a laptop
gets immediate until d of zero
and future discounted utility of v
so um and now the social planner is not
present bias and seeks to maximize the
utility of 1413 students
from his perspective okay
first question show that students are
just indifferent between
using and not uh not using their laptop
in the current class if
l equals beta times b explain why
students with lower values of l
so that's like l being lower than beta d
don't use laptops but students with
higher values of
l so l exceeds beta d do use laptops in
class
okay so now what we're going to do is
we're going to write down the utilities
from the two choices
uh that's essentially already given in
the in
in the explanation except for that we
need to be careful where
where the beta comes in right so if
students use a laptop in class they get
the immediate benefit of
l and then in the future they get what's
discounted by beta which is beta times v
minus
d right because both b and d are very
far in the future these are the benefits
or the diminished benefits v minus e
that they get in the future
l is in the present so there's no beta
here
instead if somebody uses no laptop the
students get zero so there's no laptop
benefits
in the present and the benefits in the
future
are the value of the lecture in the
future is undiminished
which means essentially it's just v so
the the person just gets zero plus beta
times v
now students who are indifferent and by
definition
um have the same utility of using
laptops and using no laptop
so we can essentially just equate those
two things uh
um it's you know notice that like the
beta times
d is always there so it's sort of
possession just cancels
and then what we get is the person
that's indifferent
for that person l equals beta times the
d
now students that choose not to use
laptops will have
low evaluations l of using the laptops
while students that choose to use the
laptops will
have high l right if the l is really if
if l is very large then it exceeds beta
times d
if l is very small then l does not
exceed is smaller than b and times c so
given sort of the indifference condition
we have essentially as i just said
students that do not use the laptop
l is smaller than beta times t and
students that use the laptop for them
l is larger than beta times t
okay okay now on question number two
now consider the policy that allows
students to use laptops only if they
sign up in advance to sit in a laptop
section it's a little bit different than
we had in class but it's a version or
something that i also considered in fact
in previous years that that was what was
used
now the question here is why is l larger
equal than d
not l is larger equal than beta d the
threshold for
opting into the laptop section
okay so now this is a choice where
people choose
not for the present whether when they
come to class whether they want to use a
laptop
right now but instead they sign up in
advance to sit in a laptop section for
the rest of the semester so essentially
people are in the present and they
choose for the future
um whether they can use laptops in class
now the utility is now different and the
key difference is that the laptop
benefits are now in the future right so
the utility of using a laptop now again
is zero in the presence this is again we
make choices for in the present for the
future
this will be no utility in the present
there's no lecture right now
no the benefits of the like um and in
the future
um uh everything is discounted by beta
now because the person is present biased
potentially so it's beta times
l plus v minus d the utility of not
using a laptop is just
zero again like in the present nothing
happens and then in the future
the benefits as before a beta times b so
the only thing if you compare
um this choice or this just these two
options
the previous version is the l now is
discounted by beta but
but before it was not let me just go
back here
so here you see um the l was like sort
of um
here you see the l is um not discounted
by beta this is when people make
choices for the present instead here now
the l is discounted by beta because that
choice is
uh the laptop benefits are in the future
now we can do the same thing as before
threshold for opting in is defined as
like or you can say this is essentially
the indifference conditions you just
equalize that you
um the utility of using laptop or not
using the laptop
and what you now get is that if l is
larger than d or larger equals indeed
then the person uses the laptop and
other otherwise
they do not
now why does the threshold not change
from beta d to
sorry from beta times d to d well
because um when laptop use can only
happen
in the future all benefits and costs are
discounted
at the same rate and that rate as beta
okay question number three assume
there's no
laptop policy at all show that if
beta times d smaller than l and smaller
than d
the student engages in preference
reversals
she perverse prefers not to use the
laptop in future classes but changes her
mind when she's actually sitting on
those future
classes
that's sort of essentially the typical
behavior of present biased people
that when they're present bias for at
least some parameter or constellations
uh people engage in present bias so
let's do the math let's see
what comes out here so when thinking
about future laptop use the student
student's problem is identical to the
problem in part
b sorry in part two why is that well
because she discounts um uh
time of both one and two periods in
advance by beta essentially everything
is in the future so you just
discounts everything by beta that's
exactly kind of the
the choice that we um just have so when
thinking about future classes we're
thinking about opting in into a laptop
section
uh the person makes a choice for the
future
so here um uh uh which thinks about any
future choices
um uh what really matters is essentially
the the
the value of the laptop is in the future
i mean back in like part two that we
just solved
um uh now uh we know from part two if
that if l equals uh smaller than d then
she would like to not use the laptop
right so we just uh solve for that in
part number two
um but from part number one we know that
beta if being a
d is smaller than l she will end up uh
using that when she's actually sitting
in the future class that is to say
if she has a choice in any given class
and shows up in class
she will say oh like using a laptop
would be great same will be true for
phones by the way
um and when she has a choice any given
class that happens right now
if beta b equals smaller than l she will
end up using the laptop
in class so that implies essentially
like a preference reversal
using these parameter assumptions
she prefers not to use the laptop in
future classes
but switches her mind or changes her
mind when she's actually sitting in
those future
classes
okay question number four
explain why the fraction one minus beta
d
of the class uses a laptop in part one
but fraction one minus d of the class
uses the laptop and part
d at part two why does a smaller share
of the class use their laptop in part
two
all right so now we're just essentially
comparing
part one and part two and i'm gonna look
at like what fraction of people are
actually
using the laptop so we can sort of do
the math version and think about like
why that
answer makes sense so in part one a
student uses the laptop if l
equals larger is larger than beta times
d
if f is the cdf of of of um
l and and and sort of and then so
there's a period missing but to define f
uh as the cdf of l and then given the
uniform
um uh distribution uh the probability
of l being larger than beta d
is one minus the the the cdf one minus f
of beta delta
which is since it's uniform it's just
one minus beta
d now likewise in part two
a student uses a laptop if l it gets
larger than d
so we have um the probability of l being
larger than d
it's one minus the cdf or f of d
which is one minus d so a smaller share
uses the laptop in part two because the
benefit of using laptop
is delayed and hence discounted by um
beta
so you know why is that well essentially
um
think about it like this if somebody has
beta equals
one which is kind of equivalent to like
part two of people make choices for the
future
if you use a laptop store a share of
people will like the laptop because
or you would like to use the laptop when
making choices for the future
not because of self-control problems
alike but just because they find laptops
really helpful and taking notes
now if then a person in addition
is present bias and makes a choice for
the present that enhances the short run
um benefits because now the l is not
discounted by beta anymore and now it's
essentially it's um
uh uh uh it's given sort of the benefit
it's it's in the present
and everything else beta is in the
future and so that means essentially
that when makeshift making choices for
the
present the present benefits the l gets
more weight
relative to everything else which is
against the weight of beta less than one
and so now if you were ready and when
making choices for the future
um choose a laptop anyway that implies
that um you also
should choose the laptop for the present
essentially anybody who chooses the
laptop for the future
will also choose the laptop for the
present and now there are some people
essentially who don't have like huge
variation they might not choose the
laptop for the future but they might
choose it
they will choose it for the present
because of their present bias
and therefore then the fraction of
people who choose for the present will
be larger than the fraction of people
who choose for the future which we just
showed using semialgebra
okay then finally why would the social
planner prefer the opt-in policy to both
the policy of allowing
students to choose whether to use their
laptops and
to banning laptops all together all
right
so let's think about to this the opt-in
policy
um what does that really um entail well
the opt-in policy as we said is
the present the the planner is not
present bias
so the planner would only want uh
students with l being larger than d
to use laptops and so the updating
policy as we just showed above
achieves this so that's great under like
a free choice policy instead
students with beta um times d smaller
than l smaller and d
will sort of optimally use their laptops
and the social planner does not like
this
on the other hand banning laptops all
together is suboptimal because welfare
is gained by allowing the students with
the highest valuations with what alec
was
sorry l larger than d to use laptops
right
so banning laptops is not great because
essentially there's some people really
would love to use that app that's
regardless of present bias
and um not allowing that is not great
free choice is not great because
essentially once you let people choose
any given day
temptation will sort of kick in and some
people will suboptimally use their
laptops and just surf on the internet
all day
uh or all class and not learn very much
and instead so the policy where people
opt in for the future
um essentially uh achieve sort of the
the the objective of the
social planner who wants only students
with l
larger than d to use their laptops um
and so the
social planner will be happy and
therefore prefer that policy
over both free choice and over banning
um laptops
okay so that's the end that's all i have
to say um about
getting ready for the exam again i think
you should prepare well
try to look at the materials please ask
any questions in case things aren't
clear
again i have office hours on friday
april
well third um uh at 4 30 to 6 i
emailed you about that luke also has
office hours from 1 30 to 3 30.
um again that's in my email um if you
have questions
um please let us know in particular on
piazza
or during office hours but in any case
please do not worry too much about the
exam try your best and
you will do great but you know even if
you don't do great you'll be fine
you will pass this class as long as you
take the exam and write something that
is remotely reasonable thank you so much
and i look forward to seeing you all in
class soon